in your comedy you've been talking about
masculinity yeah on stage you've been
going up on stage and you've been
talking about masculinity and what is it
about that subject it's really
fascinating you right now
I think masculinity is the funniest
thing in the world because it's so
pathetic and weak and I love it like the
logic of masculinity makes me laugh so
much because I'm still part of it even
though I'm conscious of I'm still an
idiot one of my friends Nick Cody who's
on the show here showing comic we were
drinking earlier this year drinking so
much because we're man and we can only
tell each other we love each other when
we're drunk because because those are
the rules
yes but you've still got to tell them
that you love them in a manly way and
the way you're doing the manly ways you
grab the back of their neck and your
point and you shout you have to shut it
yeah exactly and that's not an
appropriate way to tell someone you love
them like if those were your wedding
those like and we're sitting there and
we're screaming at each other how much
we love each other and his pregnant wife
walks by and she's seen us do this every
single time we get drunk and she's bored
of it because she knows that we should
be able to tell each other that we love
each other when we're sober we just
choose not to because we're scared how
were perceived so to try and make a joke
she went oh why don't you just kiss but
she said it's a to comedian so like we
went along with the BET and we stopped
about this distance away and here's how
masculine he works now whoever doesn't
kiss the other one is gay and the women
are laughing because that's the dumbest
thing you've ever heard right we did
you're right but the men are going woods
so what did you do I'll kiss them of
course
without any sensors yeah yeah and would
come on for 45 minutes
got a little bit excessive
you